venise la submerger les endommager la
sérénissime n'est pas au bout de ses
peines selon le maire les dommages
dépassent 1 milliard 500 millions de
dollars aujourd'hui la place saint marc
a été fermée encore une fois des sacs de
sable ont été placés derrière les
fenêtres de la basilique selon la presse
locale
pour éviter que la crypte soit à nouveau
inondés je suis vraiment déçu de ne pas
avoir pu entrer dans la basilique les
trésors de l'aar ont été gâchées par
l'eau salée ils ces tragédies ce
touriste des trottoirs surélevés ont été
retirés les touristes dont le départ
était prévu aujourd'hui on était pressé
de prendre les derniers bateaux taxis
pour regagner le continent
venise accueille bon an mal an 36
millions de touristes et si l'eau monte
la colère des résidants aussi c'est
dévastateur les clients n'entre pas à
cause de l'eau on ne vend rien dit ce
commerçant venise n'est pas un parc
aquatique c'est une vraie ville avec de
vrais citoyens 17 autres sordide
coïncide avec la hausse prévue du niveau
des mers la fréquence de ce genre
d'événement est appelé à augmenter
expliquent ces scientifiques italiens
entre temps les digues flottantes
retardé en raison de vices et d' enquête
pour corruption se font attendre
le premier ministre italien promet
qu'elles seront prêtes en 2021 avec dix
ans de retard
ici andré en côte et ce alors en rade
canada montréal